[Music]  let me break it down welcome to the east  to the perfection  remember only pretty dolls will meet  their perfect human match you're an  engineer slash model you're a boy doll  model do you honestly think your little  band of sock puppets stands a chance to  you it's probably better if you just go  back where you belong  are we really not good enough for the  big world you know what we're not going  anywhere they're all worth fighting for  in a second don't you hard pass ooh ooh  ooh another swing  [Music]  isn't that right gibberish cat  nothing is gonna stop us now leave him  the love cause he's going forever I'm  over here there's nothing we could have  done you do know that Lou is gonna make  it super hard for you well I say bring  it on Louis oh my doll  [Music]